[Musique]
ça va recommencer
noël approche la ruée vers les magasins
les départs en masse
ça recommence après un mois d'accalmie
relative paris risque à nouveau
l'embouteillage permanent on ne parle
plus que de ça et le préfet de police
annonce de nouvelles interdictions
pourtant rien ne pourra empêcher quand
un an la densité de la circulation à
paris est augmentée de 5000 voitures par
jour alors que nous avons seulement
gagné 110 km de rues en 50 ans jusqu'à
quand pourra-t-on rouler et ça roule
bien sur le trail villa au parler franc
de ce film demi-heure fournir du pont de
grenelle
moi je pense qu'une chose qu'elle est
mal réglé il faudrait me mettre moi je
foutrais d'abord pas mal de voitures en
l'air qui n'auraient ne savait rien du
tout qu'elle se promener les femmes
surtout l'après-midi et 0 bois de
boulogne
non par l'état connaissent une
interminable non aux normes ou non c'est
l'anarchie complète et tout autre
commentaire à faiblir et mes pensées et
1,2 c'était cet épouvantable moyens
toujours un monde fou et il passe quand
il peut quelquefois y en a trois ou
quatre à la suite et puis après on reste
20 minutes 12 25 minutes sans avoir
alors la faute est qui a la ratp où en
circulation mais c'est bien désorganisée
je ne sais pas par qui monsieur vient
d'être révisé paris est la ville la plus
retardataires du monde
voilà en gros ce monsieur mais non
monsieur moi je gt2 populaire relève
non monsieur vous êtes contents vous
avez mis beaucoup de contraventions ce
matin non pas une vingtaine c'est un bon
jour 20 contre les mauvais jours vous
ont été combien c'est vrai que les
contractuels touchent une prime sur les
contentions qui donne qui se fait que
les cavs à libreville ainsi la vue vous
associez s'entame serment où il a appris
le plus alors l'art est vrai qu est ce
que vous feriez alors si vous étiez
prises pour améliorer ou la folie c'est
vrai je ferai les cafés noirs mois à
l'américaine je crois que c est quand
même le spécialiste numéro 1 sans doute
de ce problème à paris satisfait la
circulation en ce moment ce moment où la
circulation est assez bonne à paris
vous savez qu'il ya un groupe
d'architectes dans paris qui a fait un
projet qui a émis le voeu on puisse
arriver à faire avec les voies déjà
existantes
un système de voies transversales et
latérale de voix circulation continue
ouais ben moi je suis obligé d'être
réaliste par conséquent de maintenir
pour l'instant au niveau du sol le
parisien exige de la préfecture de
police la solution de problèmes
quotidiens
n
n'exige pas la solution de problèmes qui
se poseront en l'an 2000
alors je pense que les il est
l'architecte sont très intéressantes et
le féconde imagination il fait don de
l'esprit mais pour moi je dois me tenir
à égale distance des vues de l'esprit et
des recettes de la tante marie les
personnes de mon âge peuvent en
témoigner
on circule beaucoup mieux qu'en 1930 où
vous tous les soirs place de l'opéra il
y avait deux encombrements qui durait
une heure et avec infiniment moins de
voitures google alors qu'on puise ont
pensé que ça va s'améliorer
conclusion il ne faut jamais être
satisfait de semaine mais il n'y a pas
lieu d'être pessimiste puisque malgré
les difficultés que nous avons analysés
au début je crois que sauf exception la
circulation à paris n'est pas mauvaise
et elle le soutien très honorablement la
comparaison des circulations new york
voie lente mais si les chauffeurs de
taxi à la fin de la journée vous n'avez
pas l'impression de perdre le contrôle
de vos nerfs non parce que nous sommes
des hommes sages des vieux sage qui a
une somme de la circulation nous sommes
la circulation mais il n'est pas ainsi
autour les jeunes mais pas l'impression
que l'automobiliste moyen perd un peu le
contrôle de ses nerfs la friedrich
certainement y la vie de gens comme à
l'entraînement
monsieur mais très certainement ce sont
des bêtes sauvages entre les chauffeurs
de taxi n'ont pas la réputation de
houston un gars d'agadez
personnellement je vous proposes tu je
vois charge de rouge pareil je suis
ouvert je vois que dix mètres plus loin
qu'ils aient leur mot d ajouts à une
voiture qui vient à ma droite
à ma droite à ma gauche dire je suis
prioritaire je les sais pas si je sais
que je bats pouvoir il dit m
autour du magasin de la même chose
j'avais une dame qui va au magasin qui
n'a
la tournée d'ivoire autour du magasin de
se placer des voitures de particuliers
il faut qu'il s'arrête quelque part je
suis les chasser sur le stationnement et
gsm visa et uniquement le stationner
cette question de cas qui nettoie les
pouvoirs qui vive face qui curieux pour
ça qu'ils passent bd e-banking soit en
hauteur soit sous terrain parce que même
dans paris nous avons encore des
emplacements souterrain qui peuvent le
faire
c'est un fait de l'argent mais il fut
pas qu'est ce que vous pensez des
projets de monsieur pas pondu par cette
prise en particulier qui transforme un
simple heures sa forme de mesures dont
vous avez entendu parler
alors pour moi c'est pourquoi c'est zéro
ça nous vient prévues concernent au
parlement très jeunes inventent un
mouvement d'envergure mais ils sont cons
movies à lévis éric il est en
particulier un groupe d'architectes qui
a fait un projet selon lequel on
pourrait diviser paris en plusieurs voix
qu'on appelle la circulation continue
c'est à dire qu on supprimerait les
carrefours il y aurait peut-être trois
feux rouges sur un axe nord-sud sur un
axe est ouest
vincennes neuilly voilà et en relayant
en ville et voilà oui là bas se lave
linge ou pas oui bas du tableau en
pratique ces paroles il ya pas de
stratégie mais il y aura un petit peu le
système d'ailleurs j'y suis allé deux
fois nous y sommes dans l'après midi
j'ai vu que les taxis des livreurs les
autobus les piétons vous pensez que les
piétons interviendront alors un type à
messieurs l'illinois remet ce dont on
vous accuse surtout c'est très égoïste
pas vous occuper des voitures qui sont
derrière vous non on peut
dans l'impossibilité de nos moyens
combien de temps ça dure à peu près une
livraison en moyenne une dizaine de
villes en dix minutes on peut boucher un
bon quartier travaille ça va forcément
si on reste dans le milieu du chemin ça
du soir oui mais la plupart du temps
vous restez dans les noms se dégagent
on essaye de dégager sur peu pareil ça
roule derrière bien entendu le choc dont
les habitués ça râle c'est à dire qu'est
ce qui se passe t il si duplex quels
sont selon vous les principales raisons
des embouteillages dans pareil vous avez
les gens qui testent leur voiture
s'ouvre et nuit le long du droit demain
c'est à cela qu'on devrait interdire de
faire ça des parkings y en a y'en a pas
beaucoup dans eyes est parti de monsieur
un feuilleton quarantaine qui ne leur
apprend - vous avez dit certaines
personnes qui me posent pour faire eux
même temps les faire leur marché sans
leur voiture
sa joie journellement se met d'accord
mais vous ne pouvez pas empêcher
quelqu'un de prendre sa voiture s'il a
envie de servir sa voiture en prenant
certainement à bien avec eux ils payent
pour mais quand même et certaines gens
devraient comprendre quand même nous
faut qu'on le fasse capable tout et le
concombre une rue au vert quelques
emplettes et qu'il être à moi chapeau la
maison et alou diarra s'est lui aussi
saint malo messina
alors là faut sortir 2 et d'agencés la
grotte infinera puis va faire un client
dans une rue moi j'en perd une dent
attendre un autre genre prend la voiture
suit leur trouve et où je gère ça c'est
lui qu'il fait les banques
il faut qu'on s'arrête en douleur
l'épicé sens unique l on est mort on
faire le tour
impression vous gêner la circulation
[Musique]
hariri
[Applaudissements]
les brocanteurs qui s'emballe paulo
mumbai
tu vois henri je demande c'est ça qu'ils
pensent
celui qui forme pour le plein la plus
grosse panique dans paris c'est toujours
un chauffeur livreur qui a tort plus
monte à l'aigle est celle d'une union
ciu pas plus gros de colo en bon verre
je parle pas de la famille parle du
paquet et ben allez quoi prêtre la
preuve alors exactement voilà pourquoi
on perd du temps et les livraisons
l'embouteillage a transmis comme ça l'a
pas bien bon et sur une grande avenue
mais quand on est dans une petite rue
liébin alors les coudes clayton les
orioles avaient fait tout ça c'est bon
nous ce que vous livrer la situe là
ouais bon pour y travailler a livré le
lâchent dans la soirée par exemple à
partir de 21h car au figuré car coiffeur
j'ai travaillé toute la journée à rester
ouverts pour attendre soins
bah oui on parle at elle encore est il
bien savoir je peux plus te retrouver
dans le sac d'oignon le terrain dès lors
la leaf fait de l'oeil qui arrive ça va
être encore par quelque chose de bien un
groupe d'architectes s'est penché sur le
plan de paris et en a tiré quelques
conclusions nom de plan de voix en
guinée pour voir peut tous nous sommes
dans un système actuellement menti
circulatoire si vous trouvez devant un
système qui est en fermant pétrifié et
qui ne bougent que par accident
on peut dire qu'on n'a pas organisé la
circulation mais on à organiser
méthodiquement du pliage sur l'ensemble
de la ville le principe de notre projet
est très simple ce sont des voies
circulation continue qui relie les voies
existantes actuellement arrivant au nord
de paris
25e au sud de même concept de l'ouest
vers l'est
les piétons passent par des passages
souterrains
nous avons ici un schéma sur laquelle
pour présenter les grandes artères qui
arrive à paris et nos rayons
la voix du nord au sud par un certain
nombre de trajets que vous voyez ici
trajet qui existe déjà un trajet qui
utilisent des voies existantes bien
entendu c'est toujours le même principe
et est ouest dans l'autre sens comme
ceci vous retrouver par exemple ici la
loi est ouest qui est la principale
champs-elysées celle ci est celle ci
nous avons par conséquent un réticule
ajout d'un certain nombre de voix est
ouest nord sud sur l'ensemble de la
ville qui vous défie divise la ville en
un certain nombre d' îlots de quartier
les quartiers plutôt que 10 lots alors
une fois c'est ce quadrillage effectué
une fois sa quatrième effectué vous nous
aménageons c'est carrefour qui sont les
carrefours à deux niveaux dont on vous a
parlé
les carrefours sont aménagés sur le
système du trèfle comme ça se passe sur
les autoroutes que tout le monde connaît
dans la ville on aura également des
cartes faut qu'ils n'auront peut-être
pas les mêmes directions que les
précédents avec des formes de voix qui
seront différentes mais le principe sera
exactement le même sinon qu'il utilisera
des voyages vous voulez aller sur votre
gauche
de l'autre côté vous prenez vous
dépassez le carrefour prenait cette
voiture aux caves et vous tournez de
cette façon dans l'autre sens
j'utilise nous dépasse également car
proulx et vous tournez de cette façon
exactement la même chose
monsieur clignotera en tant que
rapporteur général du budget de la ville
de paris vous avez été amené j'imagine à
vous pencher sur le problème de la
circulation
je vais vous demander d'abord quelle est
selon vous la raison profonde la raison
générale de la situation actuelle qui
est de plus en plus critique
vous parlez de la circulation parce que
la circulation est un problème qui tape
sur les nerfs de tous les parisiens mais
la vérité vous auriez pu m'interroger
sur les hôpitaux sur les écoles sur les
stades sur les traductions dont les
égouts ou sur la saleté choquant de la
capitale
ma réponse était la même il n'y a
personne à paris qui fasse la synthèse
et qui prennent des décisions à paris
peuvent tout le monde se mêle de tout il
n'y a pas un responsable qui puisse
trouver des solutions les appliquer et
acquis ensuite la population à qui
ensuite la population puisse demander
des comptes
mais quel est maintenant selon vous la
série de raisons techniques de raison
précise des embouteillages actuelle des
difficultés actuelles pour citer un
exemple de l'autre jour nous étions
allés le président du conseil municipal
le préfet et moi inaugurer
un morceau du boulevard périphérique
dans le xiiie arrondissement et en
revenant le préfet était prêt si nous
étions tous pressés on a vu tout cortège
est bloqué dans une rue par une un
véhicule des ordures ménagères qui
bloquaient la circulation sans se
préoccuper du tout que ce soit le préfet
de la seine qui derrière cherché à
savoir s'ils allaient reculer avancer
tout près de débloquer d'autres raisons
à la suite alors vous avez naturellement
le stationnement incohérent certaines
artères sont pratiquement inutilisable
pour la circulation
vous avez aussi les carrefours qui
n'étant pas de niveaux cisaille la
circulation et la ralentissent tout nour
enfin vous avez 7 ces transports publics
archaïque
je pense au métro et aux autobus aux
taxis qui ont un retard de 30 ans
si vous aviez les pleins pouvoirs
puisqu'en fait vous avez examiné
suffisamment la question si on vous
disait bon bien voilà nous vous donnons
six mois un an pour régler dans
l'immédiat pour régler d'une manière
pratique et la circulation à paris que
feriez vous vous savez prétendre régler
le problème de la circulation six mois
fait de la démagogie pure c'est comme
les problèmes scolaires on ne rattrape
pas en six mois
20 ans d'incohérences cependant six mois
on pourrait prendre quelques mesures de
bon sens en justement quelle mesure de
bon sens peut-on prend et bien puisque
nous parlions du ramassage des ordures
on pourrait assurer ce ramassage
nocturne de façon à ce qu'il soit
terminé à 7 heures du matin deuxièmement
on pourrait utiliser tous ses autobus
qui dorment dans les dépôts la ratp qui
dorment dans les dépôts la ratp parce
qu'on n'a pas de conducteur
pourquoi on n'a pas de conducteur lorsqu
on refuse de les payer en refuse de leur
donner les conditions normales que leur
offre le secteur privé ce qui fait que
lorsque la ratp a formé des conducteurs
ils sont
ébauché dans le secteur privé et le jour
où on aurait des conducteurs on pourrait
multiplier les autobus et entre la
banlieue et paris et obtenir que les
banlieusards n'utilisent pas leurs
voitures vont venir dans la capitale
enfin on pourrait dégager très
rapidement quelques grands axes rapides
à l'intérieur de paris pour les
transports publics pour réclamer en
somme un dictateur pour la circulation
je souviens pas jeunes réclament un
dictateur dans aucun domaine et pour
paris je réclame le contraire d'un
dictateur le droit commun une
municipalité ayant les mêmes droits que
la municipalité de lyon de bordeaux ma
paye par exemple
en attendant la ronde continue
[Musique]